est ce que c'est normal quand on est une
jeune fille parfois tu veux dire qu'on
peut avoir peur ni réaction de son
compagnon et que si on les nerveux trop
on va finir avec un coquard comme ça
julie fergane et vice procureur de la
république
exceptionnellement elle est sortie du
tribunal pour rencontrer des lycéens qui
entreront bientôt dans le monde du
travail les métiers de l'hôtellerie les
violences sexistes le sujet les concerne
déjà qu'en famille et que parent on
traite de femmes très de tous les noms
et ben voilà c'est un peu si un peu
choquant et décevant un montant beaucoup
de personnel de la restauration voire
même de clients ont des comportements
déplacés sur parce que ben la serveuse
garde entre glee mais cette image de
petite femme à tout faire on va dire et
je dirais être serveuse c'est un métier
comment casser cette chaîne de violence
la magistrate va déconstruire pendant
une heure les stéréotypes les clichés
sur les hommes et les femmes possible de
faire pour les garçons et pas pour les
filles dans vos métiers et qui est pas
vrai du tout le garçon va devait les
assiettes propre aux clients la fille
débarrassera au menu pour ces lycéens
une étude de publicité qui bien sûr use
et abuse des stéréotypes
fille en rose qui font de la danse et
garçons qui vont chez papa du rugby non
un lit violence qu'elle soit raciste
pour viendra en parler
qu'elle soit à sexistes ou sexuelles
elles viennent aussi lé tout un tas
d'imagés qu'on a la prévention contre
les violences at elle sa place au lycée
la magistrate n'a aucun doute on sait
très bien qu'à l'école circule aussi des
contenus violents et pornographiques de
plus en plus jeune et que ne pas nous
porter une parole qui est celle de
l'adulte de la loi des institutions
c'est laisser le champ aussi à des
choses qui de toute façon sont
choquantes et violente
la magistrate là aussi répété cent
quarante six femmes sont mortes sous les
coups de leur compagnon
l'an dernier en france